on Tuesday mainstream media outlets
perfectly embodied their progressive
feminist philosophies by criticizing
Melania Trump's Footwear how empowering
we'll discuss with our brand-new
cultural correspondent we'll bring him
on a little later plus an all-female
panel of deplorable x' featuring roaming
millennial allie Stuckey and the man
depressed DiGiacomo
to discuss fake news about defense
secretary mattis defying trump
on transgender policy the us
successfully shooting down a
medium-range missile near Hawaii and
fury over evangelicals Nashville
statement opposing the sexual revolution
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show I can't wait to
bring on our brand-new cultural
correspondent today you know that that's
actually how I got my start in all of
this I was the cultural correspondent
here at the Daily wire on the Andrew
Clavin show so I figured it'd be good to
pay it forward a little bit
bring some kid on you know give him give
him his start in all of this too
we're gonna bring him on a little later
but first we have to talk about this
great triumph of feminism in this age of
trumpian misogyny where women are judged
on trivial issues and things like their
looks thank goodness we have the
mainstream media to set things right
high heels for high waters the president
in first lady depart Washington for
flood ravaged Texas Melania turned heads
in a pair of black snakeskin stilettos
high-water pants and an army green
bomber jacket aviator sunglasses despite
the rain completed the Top Gun look an
aid carried two pieces of Louie Vuitton
luggage presumably containing a change
of clothes to Air Force One critics were
quick to judge milania's fashion choices
especially those high heels this was the
headline in vogue Melania Trump's
hurricane stilettos and the White
House's continual failure to understand
optics Twitterverse exploded
someone tell Melania she might want a
pair of rain boots went one comment
she's wearing stilettos so out of touch
one another it is inspiring how far
we've come it almost brings a tear to
your eye doesn't wash
that's its she always looks great that
was not the only example of this we we
have to cut to the Telegraph for their
breaking news on this issue and I'll
narrate it because they keep throwing
text up on the screen
[Music]
hang on is Melania preparing stilettos
to visit Houston supplies yes America's
first lady has opted for very practical
Footwear
ha ha ha just goes on and on that The
Telegraph is not out of sync with the
rest of the mainstream media here from
the New York Times Melania Trump off to
Texas finds herself on thin heels
ink.com yes it matters that Melania
Trump wore five-inch stilettos on trip
to view Harvey devastation slate what
was Melania Trump thinking with her
hurricane Harvey stilettos Vanity Fair
who wears stilettos to a hurricane
Melania Trump Washington Post there was
no pretense about milania's heels but
sometimes a little pretense helps that
went on to follow it be followed by an
820 word article describing this great
faux pas this great injustice and then
she changed her shoes on the plane by
the way so she only wore the stilettos
out of the White House to then go on the
plane to Texas where she changed into
something more suitable to that climate
and I guarantee you if she had walked
out of the White House wearing sneakers
all it would have been exactly the same
except the headlines would have all been
about how Melania Trump is disrespecting
the White House by wearing sneakers it's
really really hard to win with these
people now the issue here too is that
Melania Trump has been a wonderful first
lady people said that she was going to
be tawdry she was a model
she took scantily clad photos this and
that she has comported herself with
utter grace
let's compare her to recent Democrat
first ladies she never said that the
election of her husband was the first
time she's proud of her country she
never stole valor and said that she was
under a bosnian sniper fire as she never
slandered her husband's sexual victims
and called them bimbos and so she's been
axle she's an excellent role model for
women and the supposedly feminist media
have to attack her for her choice and
shoes disingenuously and this is sort of
ironic because I have looked into a
little the history of high heels and
there are a couple theories on this one
theory from Elizabeth Similac who's the
curator for the Bata Shoe Museum I'm
sure many of you have been there said
that they originated from male horse
riders in the Middle East in the ninth
century and that the heels were such
that they would allow your foot to sit
more firmly in the stirrups while you
were going out and killing people so by
that theory it's actually a very
practical shoe and then another theory
is that it started in the 16th century
with European nobility a catherine de
medici queen elizabeth who wore it to
her i'm sorry for mary the first of
england who wore it too and make them
look taller make them look larger than
life and give them stature so shockingly
there was one person on the left who
came to milania's defense because
Melania Trump apparently did something
much worse yeah you see she went to
Houston wearing high heels oh and she's
getting a lot of flack for its online
predominantly but it counts and here's
my thing I don't know why anyone should
care what anyone wears when they're on
their way to help people and people were
like why is she wearing those heels when
she's gonna help people like who cares
look at the Pope you see how he dresses
look at oh why would John bleed looks
like he's going to a p-diddy party like
but we don't say hey you can't go out
helping people dressed like that and I
know some people like Trevor it's not
about that it's about sensitivity you
don't wear things like that to a
disaster zone and I understand that but
in milania's defense she lives in a
permanent disaster zone and that's what
she always wears you know that Pope line
is I think the first time Trevor Noah
has ever approximated a joke which was
pretty good for him but also if the
mainstream media the left-wing media
have lost Trevor Noah the you know Jon
Stewart's air at the Daily Show on
Comedy Central they have really lost
everything so with that I want to end
this a little bit early and bring on my
brand-new cultural correspondent we've
been looking around since I started this
show it's very important to me that we
give the next generation a chance to
come up and teach old fogies like me
something that you know maybe I don't
know about the culture so let's bring
them on we have our new Michael Nolt
show cultural correspondent Andy Andy
millennial thanks for coming on yo Andy
as a millennial what is your take on our
culture broadly
right now well speaking as a millennial
and I have to speak as a little
millennial because I've never read a
book and I haven't seen a movie that was
made before 2007 so when I say speaking
as a millennial that's actually the only
thing I can bring to this conversation
of my millennial miss you know my
Mallette my essential millennial miss my
millennialism you might say and and as a
millennial I think I can speak for all
Millennials and can tell you the kind of
world in which we Millennials live and
so that's why I referenced that whenever
I say anything whatsoever and I you know
I think as a millennial I feel that the
culture is in serious trouble you know
we have these new things that we you
know rock and roll music I think is
making people you know immoral we have
[Laughter]
our our new cultural correspondent
Andrew Klavan famed novelist and Daily
wires show host I I did almost break on
the I am a millennial and so because I
haven't read a book you know remember on
election night with a perfectly straight
face as to be a senator Warren do you
when you look at mr. Trump do you ever
feel your fingers itch in for the
tomahawk the pinnacle of my deadpan you
know that big blonde wig and a
millennial do thank you for coming on a
pleasure we have saw what you were doing
in here
these young walks into a little room
thank you sir so we have to talk about
one of our favorite subjects yes
feminism that we have you talked about
this wonderfully feminist response to
Melania yeah and you know one of our
favorite websites and I will take credit
for you for introducing this is everyday
feminism calm yeah a true work of art
I'm not convinced it's not satire what
why has feminism become such a force I
think just about everything I mean first
of all this thing with eat with stiletto
heels was unbelievable there's Trump
hatred you know it's wonderful is all
these people in Texas are obviously
rising to this level of nobility and
grandeur and heroism and they're all the
people that the media hates is making
themselves look so bad you know I think
the left is the same thing over and over
again they decide that there's an
injustice and then they adopt the values
of the oppressor or the person they
think of is the oppressor so they think
that men have oppressed women which by
the way in the West completely untrue
right I mean that that's the first thing
I mean the thing is in a society that's
just starting out and this week women
have a very special role to play which
is the role of burying children and you
have to protect them and you have to
keep them out away from the wars and
things like that
we're so safe now that a lot of that
stuff is gone by the boards but that's
only because in the modern world were so
safe so they decide there's this
injustice and then they say well we want
to be you what the oppressor is so if
men are making money why can't women
make money if men work why should women
work if if men are strong why shouldn't
women you know enter dying younger why
shouldn't women die who and which now
they do right there and it's so dumb
because essentially men and women are
the only kinds of people who are
different I don't really believe the
black people and white people are
different per se you know I'm its
culture it has a lot of effects but you
know but men and women are actually
different they actually have different
strengths different qualities different
things that make the men that make them
women and sure there's always a bell
curve you know there's always different
people who've fallen right not not all
manner as macho as you and I know some
are more
of course you know I think you can't
expect that kind of level very top of
the mantra though but but you know I
think this whole idea that we should
value women and conservatives fall for
it to they'll say you know you want to
see feminism how about a woman with a
gun I think you want to see feminine
woman with a baby it's probably scarier
to probably going to a day exactly you
know how about a woman who's nurturing
how that a woman who's tender how about
a woman who doesn't care as much about
money because she's doing something more
important you know they even have these
things where they'll say if you paid a
housewife for everything she did it
would cost millions actually if you paid
a housewife for the actual physical
labor she did wouldn't cost very much at
all
what she's devoting to it creating a
home and creating a moral universe and
creating a family that's invaluable you
can making the man's sane and you know
making a man a man you know yeah that's
right you know sweet little Lisa's been
gone now for a couple weeks visiting her
family I know my life is in shambles my
apartment is just not true Michael we
had a great time shooting that's all I
do is I go shooting and drinking that's
pretty much all I've been up to my wife
leaves town about two days later I'm out
in the woods hunting deer with my teeth
now I'm just running down dear yeah no I
mean I think that is and they say well
why should why should a woman only have
value in what she does for a man
anything well we all have value and what
we do for one another as rightful you
know so it's just it's just a an
absolutely materialist greed that has
adopted the values of the people the
supposed values of the people they hate
you know you see it with like an Tifa
right and Tifa they say that the
fascists for the oppressors and so they
become fascist that's right they
literally wear black shirts you know
yeah do you think this has always been
inherent in feminism it with you know
this indiscernible 'ti of the sexes the
sexes women should just be men the sexes
should be the same they can't compliment
one another has that always been in
first way of second wave feminism or is
it is it blossoming now is it something
new I think it's a question of
revolution evening its own children I
have a theory that a lot of these
changes
come at the time that they're supposed
to come you know that that when women
when this the civilization gets
established women start asking for more
rights because they're let there in a
way they're less valuable as women
children become less valuable
so women become less valuable as the
bearers of children and so they want
more things to do they give them value I
think that feminists attach themselves
to those changes I was there you know as
a millennial I was there when some of
this stuff was getting started
and it was pretty easy you know women
said we want to get in we want to work
we want to do these things every thought
that's fair you know that's that's
pretty fair but the feminists the
radical feminists attach themselves to
that right and then essentially accuse
you if you oppose feminism and I am an
anti-feminist I'm I'm not like a you
know sort of pro feminist I'm an
anti-feminist but they accused you
thinking that women shouldn't have
choices and rights I believe a woman
should choose whatever she wants to do
each one is an individual I believe in
it on an individualist whenever the
circle of feminism and the circle of
individualism intersect suppose lucky
you're gonna find that but as we see
with Melania Trump they're not really
offering freedom what they're really
offering is another way of a prep what
they want to do is turn the oppression
on us they want to say well women were
oppressed now men will be oppressed
right you know that's not that's no way
to build a society I think the changes
that came for women the giving them more
you know choices and things like that
are great but I really think this wave
of feminism has accomplished nothing but
bad and has attached itself to those
good changes and sort of said we did
that when they just didn't yeah it seems
this third wave seems destructive in a
in both a practical sense but also in a
theoretical sense that seems as
post-structuralist it a lot of these
theorists they use lowercase letters to
to write their names I mean is it's
attached to an intellectual movement
that deconstructs culture and you know I
think it was Chesterton wrote that
feminists posit something to the effect
of feminists posit that when a woman
serves her boss that's freedom and when
a woman helps her husband to that slave
I always say that I didn't know traitors
and said they basically save you
serve a man who loves you and we will
dedicate his life to you and we'll help
you raise your children I'll help you
support dedicated to a guy who would
back over you and not even notice you
were dead you know I mean that's it
makes absolutely no sense and it really
you know it's something very important
because the entire human perception of
the world is divided into yin and yang
but the simple reason that there are men
and women you know I mean they always
want to say well men and women are
exactly the same but a transgender guy
is a man with a woman inside you say
well wait how does he know how does he
know he's a man with a woman who's just
a dolt is a double man what's the diff
you know so they're they're really
taking something very essential to the
human perception of the world and
damaging it making people afraid to
acknowledge it and trying to believe
people out of acknowledging it I think
it has made speaking as a millennial I
think there's made millennial dating a
nightmare I think it's made millennial
marriage a nightmare I think people
don't know and you know what else it's
done it's ruined two movies like you
can't go to a movie and see the girl get
rescued anymore because she's supposed
to be so strong and it's boring not to
see the girl get rescued most women have
that fantasy and every man wants to
rescue or Manette's all we want to do
it's all we do that is all we look for
yeah that is true I speaking as a
millennial as well I I you have noticed
that that you know I mean I haven't
dated in about a hundred thousand years
at this point but you don't you don't
ask women on dates it's all this kind of
hanging out it's the way that you would
talk to a buddy sex is easier which is
cool I mean that's great guys yeah
absolutely but it is destructive and you
know your novels yeah don't present a
feminist vision of the world because I
believe it's true I mean I you know I
present women who are tough or manly or
masculine or stuff like that but I will
not write women the way feminists write
women because I've never met a woman who
resembled anything like those women I
mean you know I've met women who were
very tough I've met women who are very
manly you know masculine but they're
still not there's still women at some
level and I just really
don't write feminism because it doesn't
exist it doesn't exist as an actual real
thing it just doesn't ring true it
represents a vision of the world that
none of us in our experience yeah
believes to be true even the people who
were propagating it probably that's
right well of course that's why they you
know that's why you get these things
where they say like I was so upset that
he said you know women aren't the same
as men that I I almost fainted you know
wait what he called me emotional I
almost burst into tears and it's just it
doesn't make any sense in it and you
know college professors can afford to
lie but novelists already fiction they
have to tell the truth that's right yeah
speaking of your stories that don't
present a feminist view of the world
I'll say we've got one that we're
working on around the clock in this
broom closet of a studio in this very
room we are creating the cure for the
clave on this weekend another Kingdom
you are on which by the way and this is
the only nice thing I will ever say to
you ever you are doing an excellent job
you are the performer of this story that
I wrote and you I'm watching you act it
out and do the voices and all this stuff
and it's really actually almost some
talent did we get that on tape no you're
really just ruining the ego and you put
that on my IMDB or something first
no thank you very much I mean even I'm
listening to it going hey this is pretty
entertaining it is it is a great story
it's really great it does ring a little
true to me because it's a bad this
failed Hollywood guy wanders into a
kingdom that is probably less surreal
than Sepulveda Boulevard that walked off
of the studios but it's gonna be rough
and we're releasing it actually don't
know exactly when we're releasing its
it's gonna be shortly after Labor Day
and we're gonna bring it out on Fridays
to make up for the you because you don't
have a show on Friday I don't have a
show on Friday either our desperate fans
will and hopefully they'll stave off
some of these disasters yeah yeah
the world the world needs something to
fill that yeah that's right absolutely
so we'll try we'll release it hopefully
a little after Labor Day it will be a
weekend release we'll do like one
Episode a week and people can write in
and send all their angry comments
excellent well Andy Andy millennial
thank you for being here it's a pleasure
to have this great new cultural
correspondent Andy millennial everybody
thank you thank you very much thank you
now we have to bring on our panel of
deplorable zand for this wonderful
feminist episode we have an all-female
panel of deplorable
ladies sorry to keep you waiting we have
the Daily wires Amanda presto Giacomo
the blazes Allie Stuckey and of course
roaming millennial ladies none of you
would call yourselves feminists is that
is that right is that fair to say yeah I
would think so Nellie
was there ever a time when you would
have called yourself a feminist or was
there some awakening you had when you
realize these people were out of their
minds and miserable or have you always
realized a correct vision of the world
well I think I'm gonna stun the masses
here a little bit I'm probably closer
now to calling myself a feminist than I
used to be it's not because that I've
changed but I've kind of realized that I
I don't believe that the left should be
able to monopolize every positive word
that we have and if feminism at its core
just means the value of human beings are
equal then absolutely I believe that I
simply disagree with the fact that we
have to only focus on my aggressions and
on demand abortion and free birth
control in order to be a feminist so I
wouldn't say that call myself a feminist
however I don't think that third wave
feminism she'd be able to define
feminism for everyone fair enough but
don't you think they always say this
feminists always say well feminism just
means you believe in equal rights for
everybody well then why isn't it called
everybody ISM it's it seems to me
disingenuous because in all of our
recent experience feminists use that
line and then spat a bunch of nonsense
that has little to do with with equal
rights but I do see your point who wants
to elite let the left keep this roaming
is there any
turn ative message to feminism that we
can offer we as conservatives can offer
to win them well I think just
egalitarian ISM you know feminists
always talk about how feminism just
means equality well then why don't we
just use the word equality right I mean
and that's what a Galit arianism is and
you know let's say that we really do
just want to make feminism all about
equality we can't escape the fact that
feminism isn't it's not just a word
right with a meaning it's an entire
political movement with its own set of
beliefs that I think the longer and you
know farther removed we are from first
and second wave feminism feminism the
more this third wave craziness gets
established the more regressive it's
actually becoming so you know as
conservatives I don't think we need to
be afraid to say that we're not
feminists or need to be afraid of being
critical of feminism but you know it
does sound bad to some people especially
those on the left or you say yeah I'm
not feminist I think we need to be
really vocal not only about disavowing
feminism but also about explaining why
and talking about actual instances of
equality absolutely I've been trying to
do that my whole life because all I
really care about is having women like
me that is basically the main motivator
in in my life Amanda I know that one of
your favorite hobbies is irritating
feminists and making them cry and it is
a very fun hobby it brings to mind that
Sandra Fluke remember Sandra Fluke that
Democrat contrivance she loved the
contraceptive subsidies and there's that
image of her and she's frowning and she
says that's not funny what is it about
pissing off feminists that's that's just
so entertaining
they're just joyless to begin with
that's why they are feminists
typically because things don't work out
for them so they're just they blame them
for any men for everything and they kind
of like sulk in their own victimhood so
joyless humorless people everyone on the
left is humorless anyhow so they kind of
fit right yeah and it's true though I
mean they're ready joyless so for though
they're just constantly spitting up this
like man-hating nonsense that makes no
sense and they're trying to rip women of
any femininity or anything that makes
them different and special and unique so
when I can bother them it's especially
satisfying but Amanda how do you really
feel you know
come on be honest right excellent that's
really wonderful now I'm very sorry to
say this to all of our viewers but we
have to say goodbye to Facebook and
YouTube if you're already a subscriber
to the daily wire thank you very much we
appreciate it it helps us keep these
lights on it helps us hire cultural
correspondents like our new one Andy
millennial and what you have to do is go
over to Daley wired.com right now it
costs $10 a month or only $100 a year to
subscribe you get me you get the Andrew
Clavin show you get the Ben Shapiro show
you get the leftist tiers tumblr a
delicious delicious way to drink up your
salty leftist ears you can have them hot
or cold it is the must-have item of the
century so go over there right now daily
wired.com we'll be right back
[Music]
[Music]
the mainstream media have breathlessly
reported that defense secretary mattes
is going rogue and defying president
Trump's ban on transgender servicemen
NPR is saying
madis puts a hold on the transgender ban
Washington Post is saying transgender
ban is frozen as Madison moves forward
USA Today mattes freezes transgender
policy but it turns out that was all
fake news in reality mattis is doing
precisely what Trump directed in a
recent White House memo roaming which is
the main culprit here for this terrible
journalism is it malice or is it
laziness I think it's a combination
right I don't think it's fair for us to
say that they only have one fault am i
right the world could end in fire or ice
what what do you think is the primary
motivator here though knowing that both
are certainly involved well I think you
know first off to be fair about this the
Trump administration has had I think a
history of a little bit of bad
communication especially with its policy
matters right they could have been more
clear about what was happening mattis
could have come out sooner there could
have been more clarity I mean they
there's like millions of people who
follow Trump on Twitter this could have
been clarified a lot sooner but at the
same time I think the media we can't act
as if they're not acting with a specific
agenda with the purpose of trying to
delete Amaya C and make it look like
Trump is doing a horrible job so yeah I
mean I think Roman you said that in a
very diplomatic way which is that there
has been some or perhaps not excellent
communication from the White House Ally
is there any disagreement between the
tweets about policy and the actual
policy agenda itself there's never any
disagreement between really where I go
for my daily dose of reality as Twitter
makes reality as he says and tweets it
exactly exactly but this whole story
obviously as we know about Maddie's
craziness is absolutely not true he
really didn't have any option or
wiggle room in the memo of whether he
was going to be able to freeze it stop
the band or anything like that that's
not even possible the only thing that he
was actually able to do was to maybe
advise Trump otherwise but he didn't
really have any wiggle room in what
Trump told him to do he is absolutely
going to carry this out and I'm not
really sure where the loss of
translation habit mm-hmm Amanda this
raises an important question shouldn't
the Democrat hacks who play journalists
on TV be focusing on other more
plausible fictional non traverses like
the Russia hack the election narrative
yeah they should definitely go back to
that one because it was so ambiguous and
there's a lot of like you know criminal
that just throwing the word criminal
gets everyone else fired up they got a
ton of mileage out of that it's come to
a close since we're seeing like ties
with the Clinton side and all this other
stuff but yeah they got a lot more
mileage out of that I mean this this lie
that they told because they're trying to
show that there's you know a lot of
volatility in the Trump administration
and maddis was sticking it to Trump
which is not true you know they tried
that and it got I would real quick I
mean even box which is basically fake
news in and of itself called out this
lie so this is not they need to go to
more ambiguous things not something so
concrete that be disproved so quickly
the ambiguity is the key on these
attacks because you never really knew
quite what they were saying about rush
it was Trump colluding Putin was the
campaign trying to get some new benefit
to the Trump corporation were they this
that it was really good they only got
one day out of this maddest fake story
but we have to move on to much less
important issues as Kim jong-un shoots
test missiles over Japan the United
States has successfully shot down a
medium-range test missile near Hawaii
one of our own test missiles not one of
that kim jong un's ally is this all to
show that miniature stalin that what we
mean business that he won't be able to
attack another island successfully or
are we actually gearing up for war here
i think that it could be it could be a
little bit of both no it's hard to
absolutely say but I think Trump meant
what he said when
we'll meet North Korea with fire and
fury if we have to now they've also said
they it's not possible to run out of
diplomatic options on that all options
are on the table I don't think that
they're gonna wait around any longer and
waste their time with cheap talk when
people's lives are at stake especially
our own people's lives so whether it's
just a form of intimidation or saying
hey we're gearing up for something big
obviously I think North Korea should
probably watch out that would be the
safe bet for a little mr. hoon roaming
this story has gotten significantly less
media attention than Melania Trump's
heels oh no we lost roaming all right
I'm leaving get me out of your work
daddy I don't want any more part of this
okay I'll I'll stick on you for that
alley that's hey that is fine by me this
is what I love about the all-female
panel of deplorable because if I had
Paul and Jacob on right now I would
cancel the show indefinitely well bro me
didn't have the right opinions so she's
gone yeah speaking of Stalinism Ally
this story this Kim jong-un's story has
gotten significantly less attention than
Melania Trump's heels do we just need do
we of course do we just need to burn the
whole MSM to the ground and create a new
one just start all over again the reason
I wake up in the morning start watching
you that is that is true we need we
might need better digs you know we've
got this brick wall over here but hey
maybe after time we can move into the
Washington Post studios or the New York
Times Amanda will this test succeed at
putting our allies at ease or are they
still nervous about mr. Trump and our
willingness to stop an attack on them no
I think I mean I think it helps I think
the plan is from the Trump
administration is that because this
problem has been kicked
you know they kick the can down the road
so many times so many different
ministration says it is kind of
Trump right now so Trump is talking
tough as he should and he's showing you
know doing these tests to show force and
kind of like ease our allies in the
meantime he's working diplomatically he
was working with China which is what he
has to do so but this this stuff first
show is good and it's important but in
the meantime hosing Trump is recommended
to put pressure on pressure on North
Korea you know to stop providing them
all this monetary support this way they
can you know their their nuclear their
utility that can kind of drop down on
the nukes that's kind of what's going on
right now and then eventually we can
handle them positive militarily or get
rid of what any nukes they have so
that's kind of the plan right now so
this stuff seems for show but it's all
part of a bigger overlapping plan that
is the show business strength of
President Trump right he does his crazy
dance over here and then in the meantime
we he has his negotiators working with
China and working with with North Korean
with our allies very strategic and
speaking of show business we have to
talk about gays left-wing leaders in the
mainstream media that I repeat myself
are up in arms
after a coalition of evangelical leaders
issued a statement affirming traditional
Christian views regarding homosexuality
and transgenderism specifically I'm
shocked I'm sure we're all shocked about
this
Amanda the nashville's statement centers
around issues of sexuality desire
orientation a gender identity as we now
call it but while it speaks at length
about homosexuality which Jesus does not
explicitly discuss in the Gospels it
doesn't mention divorce it doesn't talk
about divorce which Christ speaks
explicitly to in the New Testament is
this statement myopic like I read the
statement quickly and it's basically
about the complementarity of the sexes
and about sexual desires but I don't it
might be in there I read it quickly but
I don't remember any particular
descriptions of adultery and how the the
evangelical churches
deal with that yeah I mean so overall I
thought it was a good statement cuz this
this is the kind of stuff that's
slipping from our grip is that these
these sect these differences in biology
that the left just doesn't want to
acknowledge so I thought it was good and
that sounds and especially because this
transgender movement is moving so fast
like a freight train and it's affecting
even children I mean five-year-olds are
not exempt from the transgender movement
I mean we're singing this in
kindergarten so it was an important
statement and very useful I think they
could even gone farther and talked about
adultery and divorce and things of that
nature but but yeah overall this was it
this was needed and this was a breath of
fresh air to see you know Christian
leaders actually combating this and
going full force at them and saying this
is what we stand for and we're not going
to bend it's kind of a step towards
taking back the culture and I should
correct that a little bit I should say
it does talk about as Christ talks about
marriage and sex outside of marriage and
sex within marriage so I suppose that
could be read to mean adultery that
could be meant to describe sex before
marriage and a lot of times when people
are discussing Christ talking about
homosexuality they talk about sex
outside of marriage and the definition
of marriage but it does seem to be a
pretty basic statement of the
traditional Christian and traditional
Western view of sexuality that's why the
exploding is rather odd because this is
I don't understand what's so what's so
crazy about this I mean this has been
this has been Christianity forever so do
you think the media or painting the
shock do you think the lady doth protest
too much methinks
or do you think they really are just
ignorant of the history of their
civilization past them but but I know
you kind of see this with the feminists
a lot like they'll project a lot like
because they want you know they kind of
like yearn for that strong male figure
that they can't rest so they're just
like I don't need it
so you know it could be a little bit of
or that's just like projection and
actually the stuff does seem kind of
nice you know they have these
differences of the sexes so they just
bash it when they hear it so it could be
a combination of all these always back
to the feminism with this one it is
always back to the feminist Ally how
come all anybody on the left wants to
talk about these days is unconventional
sex if you talk about tax rates if you
talk about health care nobody cares you
can't really get them that riled up but
when you start talking about
specifically homosexual sex and
transgender identity which affect less
than 2% of the population homosexuality
is it engages 2 to 4 percent of
population transgenderism would engage
less than 2% why is this all they care
about when it's it's so such a
apparently minor issue yeah I think
that's a pretty easy question to answer
I think it's because the last not just
politically but ideologically
theologically weds sexuality with
identity which God is very clear about
that in the Bible that your sexuality is
not your identity especially if you're a
believer your identity is in Christ and
when your identity is in Christ that
comes along with some things Jesus is
very clear maybe not about specifically
homosexuality but by following him
you're denying yourself not just gay
people but anyone denying yourself
taking up your cross and following him
for some reason there's been a loss of
translation between that and
homosexuality and transgenderism and
those sins which Christianity laid out
very clearly that's what it is are no
different than anyone else's sins but
they are still sins and we are so afraid
of saying anything is right and wrong
we're so afraid of laying out morality
we're so afraid of being called bigots
that we're especially not going to say
that someone's sexual identity is wrong
and that it's antithetical to Christ's
teachings so I completely agree with
Amanda this was a refreshing just
reminder of the sanity of the Christian
Church especially if you are a believer
it was nothing new it just reiterated
everything that the Bible says and for
people who are believers they also read
this through the lens that this is the
most loving thing that you can tell
anyone no matter
what their sexual orientation is because
for the believer we believe that there
is freedom and joy found in obeying
Christ I really like what you said about
identity because a lot of times I think
people especially on the left focus a
little too much on sex they're always so
consumed with the idea of sex but the
real issue is the identity here when and
this this is true of the white
identitarian zhan their own fringe of
the right this is true of the cornucopia
of intersectional identities that people
have on the left is they attach their
identity to some creation to some
creature so you can always think of that
kid in high school who's so frustrating
and so annoying because he likes that
one band you know and you've never heard
that band before and that's really where
he finds his identity and the same is
true of all these other basically
superficial things like my skin color or
my Rachel Maddow glasses or something
something is that effect and I'm sorry
did I cut you off Amanda did you have
something to say just trying to add that
it also kind of kicks the heck out of
moral relativism do you know there are
actually moral standards that we should
that we should uphold and that is really
frightening to us because then you know
if you fall short that you feel bad
about yourself but nobody should be
shamed and need to get rid of anything
that would ever deter your actions you
should be free to do whatever you want
which again does not produce any real
happiness as we've seen so you know that
that really startled them as well that
there are actual standards and
everything is not relative you know
there are actually things you that must
be upheld which bothers them to know
what the truth above all things
absolutely ladies thank you for joining
Allie Stuckey from the blaze
Amanda presto Giacomo for The Daily wire
you know if all-female panels have
deplorable ziz feminism then sign me up
but it's not feminism so I need to put
on my smart glasses for the final
thought
ideologies by definition oversimplify
and therefore pervert our view of the
world okay ah in rationalism and
politics defines ideology as the
formalized abridgement of the supposed
substratum of rational truth contained
in the tradition by the end of that
process of theorizing the world becomes
to varying degrees unrecognizable and
this is the trouble with feminism the
vision of the world that feminism
presents simply isn't true it is
particularly destructive because it
undermines the atomic human relationship
between a man and a woman it claims that
the sexes are either irreconcilably at
odds or conversely that they're the same
indiscernible from one another but every
one of us knows that in reality neither
of those are true because fundamentally
men and women complement one another and
what a joy that is at least that is
that's what I keep telling these
all-female panels of deplorable
I am Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Doyle show get your mailbag questions in
and come back tomorrow and we'll do it
all again
[Music]
[Music]